durant trois jours le 83e salon du
fait-main s'est déroulée à la halle des
manifestations du port
un salon qui rassemble plus de 150
exposants de toute l'île des artisans
qui sous forme d'exposition vente
proposent des produits locaux et
artisanaux de qualité
l'artisanat réunionnais avec l'appui
notamment de notre collectivité
représente la ferveur que nous avons au
conseil départemental d'accompagner les
talents réunionnais notre fée main notre
savoir faire pour que demain nos notre
artisanat notre si belle artisanale
variés passe les limites et les
frontières de notre île et qu'il rayonne
à l'international pourquoi pas le
conseil départemental étaient présents
sur ce salon avec un stand réservé à sa
filière bois de goyavier un produit pays
largement plébiscité par les réunionnais
compte tenu de la qualité du travail et
des réalisations
lydéric d'autres matériaux naturels plus
connus il ya cinq ans on a développé à
l'interné une filière en proposant
divers produits et variées
pour nos besoins
des services et montrer surtout qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire avec
ce ou ces matériaux locaux aujourd'hui
on présente quand même
l'activité sur le secteur marchand le
public a pu profiter d'un atelier
d'initiation à la fabrication d'objets
mais aussi de faire l'acquisition de
mobilier ou d'articles de décoration
alors le produit standard telles que
l'époque dans son
les porte manteaux
les ustensiles de la cuisine de la salle
de bains ou voilà tout ça autour de ça à
partir du bois de goyavier et autres
matériaux locaux et une otite gamme
coin salon petit coin salon un succès
qui ne faiblit pas durant trois jours
l'enceinte portoise a accueilli de
nombreux visiteurs pour cette 83ème
édition du salon du fait main